What is the best natural treatment for multiple sclerosis?
Well, I understand multiple sclerosis is
kind of multiple causes. So
Multiple sclerosis is a demilinated disease. We need that something is
destroying the myelin sheath. So the myelin sheath is the sheath
that in your neurons in your brain. So you have
neurons in your brain that are covered in myelin and it causes the
connection, the communication along that neuron to be sped up tremendously.
So when we have a disorder that breaks down that myelin,
then we could have issues with that nerve, that nerve's communication.
It's not going to function as well. And then you end up with issues. So if it's, if you have a demilinated disease
that's demilinated motor neurons that are going to your arm, you could have issues with arm
function. You could have, you know, all sorts of problems. So depending on where that demilination is,
is where you're going to have problems. Multiple sclerosis is plaqued
of the myelin sheath and break down of that myelin sheath. So what you'll see with
audit with multiple sclerosis, if you did an antibody neural antibody test, you'll
typically have antibodies against myelin sheath cells. So you'll have antibodies against myelin.
So you'll have destruction of myelin. So it's an autoimmune disorder. Now again,
what was the cause of that could be a myriad of different causes.
Person can end up with myelin sheath and myelin antibodies post concussion.
They had a concussion 10 years ago, play in hockey and ski accident, car accident 15 years
ago. And now they're having upper motor neuron symptoms, meaning they're having issues with
with motion. They're having a function of muscles of motor neurons. They're having issues with
with sensory issues. And then you do an MRI and all you're plaqued of your myelin sheath cells,
you have demilination going on and you have multiple sclerosis. Okay, well, again,
that doesn't help at all. And all they do is give you a drug that is mildly beneficial for some
people. You have to dig into cause, you have to dig into everything that you would dig into with
an autoimmune disease. So you test for neuronal antibodies, you'll definitely see if you have plaqued
of the myelin in multiple sclerosis, you're going to definitely see myelin antibodies. Possibly
other antibodies, you look at the cross reactants to those cross reactants to myelin is gluten. So you
got to go off of some things immediately go on a gluten free diet. Also want to test for other
triggers. You want to do a Syrex array 10, at least where you're looking for other food triggers
and you're trying to calm down the immune system. Definitely go off of any immune stimulant supplements
that you're taking. Anything else you're doing to stimulate the immune system because again,
every time you still be in the immune system, when you have self antibodies, you're going to create
further destruction. So why do some people have multiple sclerosis that can manage it quite well and
they don't seem to have a lot of progression because they're doing these things. Other people,
they're multiple sclerosis progresses quite quickly because they're not doing these things.
With any autoimmune disease, you can't necessarily cure it, but you can manage it if you find your
triggers and it takes time. So don't beat yourself up but you find your triggers and you
remove those triggers and you calm down the whole response. Definitely with any neuronal antibodies
and that's with multiple sclerosis with myelin. Antibodies would follow that.
Has to be no alcohol as well. They found with studies that alcohol increases the inflammation. The
brain is going to increase the damage and destruction of the myelin. She sells. So natural treatment for
multiple sclerosis is to, it's really an autoimmune disorder so you're going down that whole autoimmune
pathway, looking for triggers, looking for things that stimulate the immune system and you're going to
calm those down, you're going to change your diet, change your nutritional protocol, make sure you
don't take any immune stimulants and you go down that pathway to discover any new triggers that you
have. Once you calm that down, you can decrease progression and really that's really the treatment.
I don't want to simplify because it isn't simple because you're digging and you have to run some tests
to find out what these are and you have to be diligent about looking for triggers and trying to
remove those from your diet. So it's not easy. I'm not saying it's easy but this is how you're going
to save your life. It's not something you should take lightly because when autoimmune disease has
multiple different phases and the more destruction you have, you have destruction of myelin. She sells.
I mean they're gone. So it's not good when that happens. So all the good endocytes are not going
to grow back. So you have to stop that progression. It's tracts as fast as possible.